البدايه من فرنسا التي تتواصل فيها
التظاهرات الحاشده ضد قانون رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 وقد اتسعت رقعه
الاحتجاجات لتعم العديد من المدن الفرنسيه
وعلى راسها العاصمه باريس كما تواصلت
الاضرابات لتطالا قطاع السياحه اذ اغلقت
رموز باريس السياحيه قصر فيرساي وبرج ايفل
امام السياح كما نظمت النقابات اضرابات
تشمل القطاعات العماليه والتعليميه كافه
وقال مراسل الجزيره ان المظاهرات انطلقت
وسط العاصمه باريس في ظل تاهب امنيا واسع
وقال وزير الداخليه الفرنسي انه نشر 13
الف شرطي بالتزامن مع التظاهرات في انحاء
البلاد وتعهد وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
بتفكيك المجموعات المتطرفه حسب تعبيره
وعدم السماح بالعنف
وتحولت الاحتجاجات في مناطق عده في فرنسا
الى اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين وقوات الامن
التي اطلقت القنابل المسيله للدموع على
المحتشين
[موسيقى]
كمان دلعت مواجهات بين قوات الامن
الفرنسيه ومتظاهرين في مدينه ليون
الجنوبيه البلاد وقد اقدم متظاهرون
فرنسيون على تحطيم ابواب مؤسسات ماليه
ومحل تجاريه في المدينه كما اغلقت الشرطه
الفرنسيه بالحواجز الحديديه شارعا رئيسيا
في المدينه اثرى الاحتجاجات المتصاعده ضد
قانون التقاعد
وكان مراسلنا قد افاد بان متظاهرين
فرنسيين احتلوا محطه سان شاير للقطارات في
مارسيليا الجنوبي البلاد الى ذلك داهم
محتاجون مطاره بياريت جنوب غربي فرنسا في
اطار الاحتجاجات المستمره رفضا لقانون
التقاعد واطلق المتظاهرون قنابل دخانيه
باتجاه مدخل المطار ما تسبب في تفعيل
سفارات الانذار وتشهد فرنسا تحركات منذ
اسابيع رفضا لرفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64
عاما